but
uh
can you take down dirty sanchez
staring at it i don't google stuff like
that martin mull there's the man oh wow
i'm working on a documentary about him
and it's taken three years and we're
coming to the end of shooting and we'll
be finishing i love martin maul you're
doing a documentary i have been for
three years and we have uh yesterday i
uh interviewed patton oswald oh my god
next week i've got tom waits i'm doing
and that'll be the love tom white who
doesn't well people that don't know him
are you familiar with who tom waits she
won't know no he's pretty damn brilliant
dude maybe if i see a picture then i
will do it
is great and he talked like it but his
voice went through so many stages and
that was because of the alcohol that he
lied about to his parents but um that's
tom waits he's been acting in things for
years you know i did a pilot with him
years ago no 1981
i did a pilot with him and dick sean
that's a gift yeah that's where i i met
him i knew his music but that's where i
met him what was the pilot those guys
are the geniuses
it wasn't uh it was called the chicken
and the cheerleaders
whoa and it was the san diego chicken it
was like i i have no art matrana who
just passed
yeah and we did it and i'm trying to
remember who is the uh executive
producer but it was it didn't go it was
just a silly little thing and then they
hired these two amazing forces yeah yeah
sean was one of robin williams
would remind me of dick shawn and
jonathan winters yes uh but but people
don't credit dick sean sometimes but i
really saw some of robin we all were
influenced by people all of us yes and
uh and dick shawn was so
brilliant he was you would love him he
was in you saw him if you saw the
producers uh the original mel brooks
movie he was uh in the play springtime
for hitler he sang it um and he was uh
he passed away
on stage it's amazing and his son it's
really sad but his son would do the
lighting or the sound for him this was
in san diego and he would start his act
he would be under a giant pile of
newspapers and leaves and stuff i saw
his show oh did you see that san
francisco oh i didn't see but he was
there the show was to begin and he was
he had passed he had a heart attack and
died and nobody knew and they thought it
was part of the act and then the son had
to run up on the stage and find his
father and take him in front of all
these people it's just a horrible tragic
as hell but maybe wonderful in a way you
know if you're well if you're going to
go out but there's no good way to go out
but if you're good doing doing it on
stage you know i don't know i don't want
to have be a corpse on in front of
people
but i mean i had a closer though i heard
it was the act break because what he
would do is oh you'd go into the theater
so they the doors a half hour before
showtime you walk in there's a pile of
leaves and newspapers on the thing and
they would play a song hail to the
audience hail to one and all
that
hail to the audience for a half hour it
was like a monty python type thing i
love it
[Music]